it's gun week the founding fathers
understood that only an armed people
could truly be a free people so this
week I invite you to join me and mud
club's resident gun Aficionado Mr guns
and gear himself as we tackle the
subject of firearms from every angle
possible in today's episode let's take
on all of the basics that you need to
know about a handgun this is handguns
101.
episode number one of guns week we're
going to be going through handguns 101
today we'll have another installment you
can click the link on Long guns rifles
shotguns debunking gun myths ballistics
this brings us our resident expert Mr
gears he's known you may know him as
guns and gear we call him Mr gear glad
to be here guns on a first name basis
yeah we can go with the guns or just
Mike okay no guns guns guns sounds like
a good handle uh it does actually there
aren't that many we've talked about
entry points for people out there uh
there are a lot of gun hobbyists and
there are a lot of videos online from
incredible speed shooting unbelievable
trick shots Feats and then people
arguing about you being an idiot for
purchasing a certain firearm using a
certain caliber this is hopefully
designed to inform you and help you look
if you haven't purchased a firearm know
what you probably need to take into
account how to be safe how to learn how
to shoot maintain it the basics and then
if you want to move on down the trail
great but it does seem like with the gun
Community sometimes they forget that
there are rungs to the latter 100 and uh
that's one of the reasons I started
doing what I do I didn't grow up around
guns at all so I didn't handle them
until I was an adult I felt really
intimidated
um thought you know you need to be
military you need to be police to know
anything about guns and it's just simply
not true and sometimes sometimes you
will get military and police who will
still espouse that say actually well you
guys don't need these right this is for
me right you know with BMI sometimes of
35 right as if they're a gate keeper to
the Second Amendment right they're
absolutely are no Gates exactly I'm not
a gun guy I'm a second amendment guy who
uh you know I carry a firearm so right
now on the table we do have a revolver
this is um my carry here we'll make sure
it's unloaded so you can see this
there's no way when there are cameras
around I'm aiming it at a hill for the
internet experts but at some point it'll
be aimed at uh something that can be
exploded uh that's my Walther here so
this is a semi-automatic and a revolver
maybe a good place to start would be
having the ladies bring out some
firearms and kind kind of going through
the process of picking a firearm a
handgun that would be appropriate for
you yep for sure all right let's bring
out the lovely ladies
thank you
there was no real specific technical
purpose for that but it was nice uh so
walk us through here for folks who may
not know sure um the Firearms first off
if you have a handgun what would be the
primary purposes uh for someone
purchasing one that's it so what I
always say about when you're trying to
pick your first gun if you want you know
choosing rifle pistol shotgun whatever
the case may be I recommend for your
first gun to get a handgun of some sort
whether it be a revolver or some
automatic which we'll get into here in a
second the reason for that is you can
always have your handgun with you most
situations you can't just run around
with an AR-15 but you can with a handgun
so it gives you options you can carry it
you can take it you know out in the
woods if you're afraid of cats whatever
the case may be yes or just don't like
them right
I don't yeah but uh but anyway so that's
why I recommend a handgun of course
there's some drawbacks to that they are
the hardest of the guns to shoot well uh
for sure but again they definitely give
you options so and those could be
especially a handgun right most likely
are you going to have it in your you
know Knights is going to be a bedside
gun right that allows you something
larger which benefit easier to control
yep
um if you're carrying it the smaller you
go the harder to control but obviously
the easier to conceal the trade right so
there's always a trade-off guns no
matter what you're you're giving up
something to get something
um so for example here on the table we
have this gun here which is Ruger 22
caliber pistol okay that would be a
great gun for someone who wants to learn
how to shoot because very low recoil not
a powerful round at all
um but the benefit of it is very very
low recoil it's not as loud as some of
the other options as well so uh the
downside of course is that 22 is not
good as like a bedside gun right right
you don't want to count on 22 to save
your life and we'll go through that in
some in a future installment here myths
associated with guns because you'll have
people say well 22 kill someone well
sure does but if they're dead four hours
later right in the hospital's not gonna
help you it's not going to help you
you're looking to you know there's a
term stopping power uh also the idea
that the 22 bounces around in your body
like a ping pong ball it's not true
that's another video yes it is uh and
explain people okay so we have nine
millimeter 380 and this is you know a
revolver and 38 357 kind of what we
think or what you think is the minimum
effective caliber why one might not sure
so my opinion is uh for self-defense
your minimum calorie you should go with
if it's a semi-auto is 380 which is this
one here that we have for the Walther
PPK
um and the reason for that is just
there's a lot of studies that have been
done on it and between 380 slash nine
millimeter up to 45 there's not a lot of
difference in terms of uh stopping power
as you just said uh in the real world if
you actually look at the data it's
pretty darn close
um but 380s will be generally speaking
smaller do you hear that that's the
sound of people going nuts in the
comments section all right I don't use a
caliber unless it starts with a four yes
yes people will that's fine I knew that
gun gear was a fairy
he's talking about the minimum effective
dose for someone who's not comfortable
necessarily correct if you are a healthy
25 year old six foot tall 200 pound man
probably not what I would recommend okay
um but then we go over here to the
Walther PPS which is a nine millimeter
but it's a smaller nine millimeter so
nine millimeter is gonna be a little bit
more powerful uh it's also going to give
you more options for defensive carry uh
better rounds uh just it's also cheaper
but a small gun like that is going to
have more recoil it's going to jump
around harder to shoot well and of
course you have less capacity and let me
show that kind of for people who may not
know you know this is uh what would be
considered more of a full size you can
see here the uh the PDP versus the PPS
it's a lot thinner it's much smaller
easier to conceal this one has a Crimson
Trace laser grips it says a red dot and
a lot of people sometimes don't take
into account that they go well small I
just want a small cute gun this is going
to be much harder to control because
there's less weight right so it's more
like a bomb going off here fire to Smith
and Wesson Scandium J frame I have
within 357 Magnum it's the most unheard
present thing I've ever shot in my life
you do one cylinder okay yeah I can get
it yeah 100
um so yeah like Steven said of course
this is a larger gun it's going to have
more capacity so this particular one's a
PDP compact standard capacity on that
one is 15 rounds but it can take
magazines that hold more more rounds is
generally speaking what you want if you
can get it I've never met anyone who's
been in a gunfight who was like I had
too many rounds right it just it doesn't
happen now the downside of that is if
you're going to carry it all day it's a
little bit bigger it's a little bit
harder to conceal but it's easier to
shoot well so you're feeling I take into
account too many Round Kenny but that's
more that's more of his calling card so
it's not relevant for sure and then this
is you know the nicest looking firearm I
would say there but this is how I
learned on these Firearms sure so this
one here is a 686 Plus I believe from
Smith and Wesson so it's chambered in
357 Magnum but for wobbers 337 Magnum
will also take 38 special and for
revolvers that is the weakest I guess
we'd say caliber that I would recommend
for defensive use it's very similar to
380 in terms of how it performs
ballistically but this gives you the
option of course to use 357 Magnum which
is a much more powerful round but it's
going to have much more recoil
um and capacity is limited with
revolvers that's one thing a lot of
people like them because they're simple
they're dead reliable for most people uh
but this is and this is you know a 686
so I think it's seven or eight rounds
but you're usually looking at five or
six correct and um to your point I
wouldn't say that revolvers are more
reliable uh that said what I would say
is uh when revolvers malfunction they
tend to be more difficult to fix whereas
with a semi-automatic gun if it hasn't
function you can just fix it very easily
typically when revolvers stops shooting
you take it to a Swiss watchmeg correct
yes it's it's just but it usually means
you've done something really bad yes I
agree with that as well yeah um but if
you're somebody who just doesn't ever
want to maintain your guns which we'll
talk about as well and you just want to
leave it in the sock drawer there's been
a ton of little old ladies that had a
six shot revolver that they haven't shot
in 20 years that have defended their
homes with it so it's definitely doable
so if we're looking for example this
might be something home defense though
there are holsters that can work
something like this for concealed carry
for someone who maybe has a little more
experience maybe a 380 for someone who
is a little recoil sensitive uh and a
revolver if you're looking to live out
your Dirty Harry fantasies or just
really don't want to ever maintain a
firearm correct I agree with that
additionally uh this particular revolver
is heavy so it's all steel and if you
put 38 specials in there it's going to
have very very minimal recoil so if you
if you're recoil sensitive at all a
heavy revolver is definitely one to look
at all right so let's bring uh Gerald in
here who owns Firearms but uh knows very
little about them has never cleaned them
look that's 100 true it's fair to entry
I don't want to clean it yeah no so I
just know not to point it at any one of
you guys on purpose so basic gun safety
because he's a large man in Clumsy yeah
what that so of course uh the basic gun
safety is keep your finger off the
trigger until you're ready to fire okay
uh know your Target and what's beyond it
meaning that if you have just a Target
out here it's going to go through it
into other things you said keep the
finger off the trigger know your target
so if I shoot one of these cameras it
will hit the person behind it uh it
might okay so that's fair yeah
especially because we have old Ghost
ghostman Camera Tim yeah that's true
yeah
which means he's non-union Additionally
the one you'll hear classically is treat
all guns like they're loaded yeah
um I'm not a big fan of that because it
inhibits some training things that you
can do dry fire also if you own like a
Glock you have to press the trigger to
disassemble it so I say know the status
of your firearm that's my personal rule
on that so if I pick a gun up and put it
down
once I put it down it's not loaded
anymore mentally and I have to re-clear
it that's kind of my rule of uh thumb on
that okay that seems to make sense I
know a lot of people will say treat
every firearm like it's loaded and so
again this is one of those things that I
think there's gonna be a little bit of
chat about firearm as though it's loaded
if it's the first time yeah but people
who say like should every firearm like
it's loaded they say well have you used
our laser system and you get to do
targets exactly it's not loaded it's a
laser but what are we doing here yeah so
uh no it's exactly right and just like
we talked about here like there's no way
at some point we've cleared all these
Firearms to make sure that's not aimed
at something that we don't want to break
but there's a nice lawn chair over there
yeah I don't want to lose that I
wouldn't say nice yeah well we spared no
expense yeah yeah and of course to that
point uh never point a firearm anything
you don't want to destroy or kill yes
last one yes okay so for people who
don't know let's go and I've gone
through this before we've done changed
my Minds Let's uh you know revolver is
relatively simple let's go to the
semi-automatic let's say this was on the
table right in the slide
was in here and there's a magazine in
there so someone handed it to you that
way there's nothing in the chamber how
would you ensure that that is safe okay
so with the semi-automatic uh first
thing you want to do is drop the
magazine this is actually
I would say one of the most common ways
that people have a negligent discharge
which is when the gun goes off and they
don't want it to if you don't drop the
magazine first and then you rack the
slide you're gonna drop right you're
going to put around the chamber rather
so drop your magazine first
lock the slide back physically inspect
and visually inspect that the firearm is
clear and now it's clear now it's clear
revolver pretty simple but for people
who don't know sure so uh revolvers are
going to open 99 of the time one of two
ways so uh it will open pushing this
button forward like this on a Smith and
Wesson style gun on a Colt gun that
works the opposite way but after that
all you need to do is look into the
chamber or excuse me the cylinder and
you can see there are no rounds so it's
unloaded okay so all of these Firearms
safe unloaded uh and I guess now we're
going to load them up and take them to
the range and some basic tips for people
like Gerald who couldn't hit the
broadside of a barn yeah I'll try I mean
come on I've gone to the range a couple
of times I've just never cleaned my gun
that's that's the problem we'll get to
that yeah never never well we'll do that
I don't know how we'll get to it after
we'll learn how to maintain your
firearms and also we'll look at some
holster options okay never really never
[Music]
okay now the fun part that you probably
all want to get to But first you should
go back and watch the safety uh ear
protection we're on the Range you oh
well those are deep in there yep okay
definitely want to get them in I
couldn't even necessarily see it you
haven't oh you have the big over ears
all right yeah eyes and years I have my
Walther PDP by the way their sponsor to
this show look the plug is just go try
one go to your local uh dealership go to
local gun range ask to try the Walther
they're they're cool they fire easily
they practically sell themselves Great
Guns um mine has a red dot on it which
we'll get into but this is a base one
we'll be using iron sights uh and some
basic shooting tips for you know the
Gerald
sure just uh when you pick a firearm up
most important thing for a new person is
to keep your finger off the trigger so
with a semi-auto it's easy just to put
it up top like that and of course you
want to be as high as possible into the
gun and the reason for that is as the
gun recoils the slide is going to be
doing this so if you're low down on the
grip then it's just going to flip more
uh you're going to have a harder time
staying on target you just want to be as
high as possible get as much purchase on
the gun as you can
and then with your other hand what you
want to do really quickly would that be
when people use the term limp wristing
yes is that the term where it's like
you're limp wristing so it doesn't The
Recoil operation isn't proper correct so
if your hand's too low
it can cause a limp wristing malfunction
like he was just talking about meaning
the slide can't go all the way back and
all the way forward to get the next
round right so that is another reason
you want to grip it nice and high but
it's gun week not Pride week so we don't
have that it's interesting here yeah
it's true and then with your support
hand you basically want to fill in as
much surface as you can on the firearm
so the way I teach it to new people
is if you make an L with your hand come
in at a 45 degree angle to the gun and
then you're basically going to be right
there and once again you want to be as
high as possible on the gun to mitigate
that slide recoil energy and you
explained to me too I think this is
important for people you're basically
trying to create a vise yes right
because the recoil operation right
thermodynamic the law thermodynamic
every action has an equal and opposite
reaction it's either going to flip up
right or of course there's instability
this way right so you're looking to
stabilize it side to side and kind of
front to back muzzle up and that's what
you're controlling with that grip for
sure okay and some people will teach a
push pull grip meaning you push with
your dominant hand and pull with your
sport hand I'm not a huge fan of that
the way I like to think of it is you
want to as you come out to present kind
of clamp like a vice just like Steven
was just saying uh up on top that's kind
of how I think of it
um there's different techniques though
but that's your basic grip and note
again for the second time finger off the
trigger great because that's what people
do so this is as close to kind of a
basic sort of uh nine millimeter that
you might you know they're similar to
their Glocks or HKS where everyone has a
double stack nine millimeter like this
right would be considered a mid-sized
full-size pistol and then we'll move to
some of the different sizes so you can
see the different Dynamics I'm going to
step away I love you I only teased them
because I knew he couldn't hear me but
uh I want Mr guns and gear to help you
handle the Firearms which one of the uh
let me ask him targets should we be
shooting I say we go with the actual the
actual Target so establish that good
grip like we talked about okay right now
you have large hands as do I so this can
be kind of a problem uh in terms of
getting as much purchase on the gun as
you can so am I resting it right it's
not a rental we do have it yeah it's
explained that for people who don't some
people may say what do you mean by
purchase okay actually so what I mean by
purchase is getting your surface area of
your hand on the surface area of the gun
you want as much as possible and his
point about his thumb where should he
keep it in order to get as much purchase
on it as you can your thumb needs to be
high so there's a grip called the two
thumbs High grip that's what you'll okay
see it referred to all the time that's
what most people should use in my
opinion with a semi-automatic gun now
should I keep it off the slide obviously
no that doesn't matter okay well it's
not going to mess with me it will not
okay all right um because I saw your
other hand coming in and it was high yep
so okay and you're sure because you're
talking to the man with the worst luck
in the world if something can go wrong
explode in his face what are we talking
about that's why we don't let him around
high points that's a fair point a wise
move all right so again you're going to
have your thumb up okay and you make an
L with your off hand and you kind of
come in at a 45 degree angle just like
that
and get what you want again is no gaps
here on the frame there's no Gap I'm
sticking my finger in there he's
grabbing my finger that's what you want
you don't want any of the gun that's not
being supported so that's pretty much
ideal okay um when we go out to present
if you turn around okay so there's two
schools of thought on this as well in
terms of presenting a firearm yeah so
some people will teach you over here
yeah some people will teach that your
arm should be bent slightly to absorb
The Recoil some people will teach
straight out
I don't think it matters I think it's a
personal preference thing honestly yeah
I really do yeah there are different
ways to connect I will tell you this so
the way I always learned again I learned
on revolvers right uh I grew up in
Canada so you know it's the magical gun
of mystery you're never supposed to know
about for sure so I first fired uh
revolvers um it was a former uh cop
actually when I was filming in Oceanside
California and uh the first time I ever
went to any kind of a course on guns
they said okay you know slightly
staggered stance then when I went to get
concealed carry uh in Texas he said no
no you have to stand completely straight
and everything you've done is wrong and
I had to relearn it even though I
learned how to shoot and I think a lot
of people will run into this sure first
off what do you prefer and and can both
work sure so for stance uh what I tell
people is most people have played some
sort of sport whether it be volleyball
basketball football whatever
what you want for a stance is a
defensive stance so yeah something like
this if you wouldn't what I'll say is if
you wouldn't throw a punch from it from
that stance don't shoot from that stance
okay does that make sense so so for me
that would have to be staggered right a
little a little stagger right yeah a
little stagger well this doesn't make I
don't like that especially I was like
you know straight like this I mean you
just felt like I could be tipped over
yep well yeah we're not going to be
blowing our knee out
but yeah so a good athletic defensive
stance okay and that can be within the
you know sort of your tolerances as to
what is comfortable for you 100 and
people have health issues and everything
else have you run into this tube gun guy
like you go to these functions you go to
these Expos and I say it because
irm owners out there as possible am I
yelling no you're fine and uh so often
I'll see people go up and they'll get
scared off and they're like oh look it's
not that hard to be safe and to be
proficient you don't need to be a world
beater right you need to find what works
for you within the parameters of safety
do you find that a lot of the time some
people are too close to the forest to
see the trees and scare folks off a
thousand percent the enthusiasts and the
Gun World they have their egos invested
in yeah so uh definitely recommend not
doing that come to it with an open mind
and you might learn some things so yeah
clear minds and Open Hearts there you go
finger off the trigger fingers are off
the trigger absolutely okay let's uh
let's uh see Gerald do this first
uh let me actually get into that okay so
for loading a gun talking about
semi-automatics uh there's two essential
ways to do it so either you can lock the
slide back first by hitting our side
lock lever here insert the magazine then
either drop it with a lever or pull it
back either one whatever okay now I've
heard people say that you're a if
you do one or the other I'm sure you've
heard this time yeah absolutely do this
and some people go absolutely hit the
slot right either one works what's the
safest way to do it for the for the for
the average person like me if you're
only going to practice one technique
running the slide works on every
semi-auto okay gotcha dropping the slide
stop does not work on every semi-auto
okay so if you just want to be
consistent run the slide well like the
Walther PPK we have correct exactly and
so that's the perfect example so
um and what you want to do when you do
that is overhand grip good purchase pull
back let go don't run with it do not run
with it that spring is sprung
to put the round of the Chamber from
that Force just let it go okay
get sprung sir
there you go all right basic side
alignment for uh
sites like this is going to be you want
everything to be centered so you said I
can either be here or I can be a little
further out
people will argue that so I would say
you want to be out no matter what right
but some people will say you want to
have Flex in your elbows and some people
will say locked and rigid
I'm gonna try a little Flex first and
see what happens sure it's gonna fire
once and see how this goes okay
good I hit the target of the target
they're not selling any meat hiding
bathing suits anymore okay good time to
mention that the ladder cutter studios
are protected by Walther one of the
leading firearm manufacturers in the
world for over 135 years go to
waltherarms.com to check them out stop
real quick if you find yourself uh
shooting four five six shots whatever
the case may be and your wrist starts
slipping uh it's because you're not
gripping it tight enough okay period uh
or your gun just doesn't have enough
texture but that's not the case with the
PDP that gun has plenty of texture yeah
no it definitely has good grip yep so
let's make those adjustments and let's
see I guess if that uh okay all right
okay
[Music]
any thoughts I like it this is the first
time I fired my PVP and that's that's
not so bad that's that's very now I'm
going pretty slow like I'm not actually
sure running through this thing no
that's that's very good for someone
who's not a proficient shooter I mean
there's a lot of people here but it also
just shows how those little those little
tips can make a huge difference it
doesn't need to be as complicated as
some folks of course if you want to be a
world competition shooter but just look
at that with those couple of tips every
single one was on target all right so
I'm gonna see if I can remember how to
do this here right so we put this guy
right there all right there we go all
right so what I one thing I would
recommend okay uh just for consistency
sake come over the top of the slide like
this like that because you have the most
power why did I do that yep so I'm going
back at this target here right so 45
again right here just so I can show you
guys so 45
right there and snug up to the top is
that about right and again just for a
check you want to make sure there's no
nothing I can get can't get in there and
get on the grip that means it's doing it
right it's gay pride month I'm not sure
if we should be doing the Pokey thing
which may not just brought on gay pride
so now we have to now but for you it's
always it's always gay pride month
trying to talk all right so one thing
too
um with your offhand grip yeah
um sometimes if you Cam it forward a
little bit more like I.E rotate your
wrist okay it'll create a stronger uh
yeah it kind of feels better yeah okay
because you're using your bones instead
of your muscles at that point to
stabilize it okay so sometimes to cam It
Forward all right and see how that works
too all right if it works for you do it
all right let's see how he does with the
smaller
[Music]
all right
the target moved
[Music]
all right so most likely but just we'll
pull the slide back most likely what he
just did there it's called riding the
slide lock
as when you have your hands up high like
that I hit that yep it hit it and
prevent it from walking back okay right
but that's fine there's okay and noticed
it was it was it was actually pretty
pretty similar to a couple shots did go
high is that for people who don't know
is that typical of a smaller firearm
it's typical that you're just not
controlling your recoil as well okay
okay that's really what it is okay so
it's my fault yeah well it's your fault
combined with physics okay Alex are
really really good with both of them
once you made those little Corrections
which is proving the point that it
doesn't have to be overly complicated to
get proficient right if we're talking
about a defensive scenario and of course
adrenaline is dumping and we understand
all those things that would be more than
serviceable for what you need 100
especially consider that you have giant
crab claws right which makes a
difference he's a large man this brings
us to you know some people now will say
don't ever use a firearm anymore in the
year 2023 without a red dot and uh and
this one and I didn't learn on any red
dots so I have the same PDP here yep the
Red Dot we'll check it I don't want to
take the yeah take the magazine
otherwise I'll put in them
so it is clear yep um and what is what
are your thoughts on this are you are
you Pro Red Dot are you anti-red dot for
people don't know iron sights right
think traditional metal sites this it's
not a laser but when you look through
this Looking Glass you will see a DOT
and that's basically supposed to make
Target acquisition uh faster and I think
for most people it does
kind of so uh if you were to ask me this
question five years ago I'd give you a
totally different answer today
red dots on pistol sides are pretty
reliable right before they're very
fragile would break the good ones now
are fine in terms of durability this is
one of them it's a whole Sun 509t
um
that said with
people who are new to guns I think it's
easier well it's easier for them to get
hits with red dots but I think it's
easier for them to get proficient with
iron sights so the reason I say that is
people who are new to Firearms when they
go out to present very often will miss
the dot I.E it's not there they don't
see it and they end up doing this a lot
of this trying to find the dot now there
is a solution for that it's called the
acss reticle but that's a video for
another day
um but my main thing is usually tipping
the gun down helps find I've almost
always noticed that if I'm looking
through the way I would look at iron
sights take it and tip it down you find
it if you miss the dot it's probably 90
that it's high okay additionally newer
guns like this PDP is actually a perfect
example the reason this
little whip right here is here there's
four red dots it's for just that to tip
it so yep so when you grip it you do
that that's literally why it's there
that's why they're designed the frame
like that that makes sense so it's to do
that to get the dot okay
um that said if you do a bunch of dry
presentations meaning uh no rounds you
just kind of come up like that
practice over and over again you
absolutely can't get it but there is a
steeper learning curve to learning red
dots on a pistol than there is on a
rifle okay
um do you do you want to try with a red
dot drill since you're kind of the
experiment here so this is an unloaded
gun but Jill try and find the Red Dot on
the target
with pistol Red Dot well any red dots
actually
um
you want to ignore your iron sights so a
lot of people will try to like lollipop
them meaning put the dot on the front
sight do not do that ignore them okay
pretend it's not there all right
so
I don't oh there it is okay there we go
I just needed to tip it down a little
bit yep but that's the problem with
pistol red dots so under stress imagine
trying to do that right I know yeah
there we go with red dots just like
lasers actually you just had out here
one of the things again with newer folks
is they want to get everything right
this is more so for women than men just
in my experience and teaching people so
it can slow them down initially now once
you get proficient the red Dot's 100
faster there's a reason all the world
championship Shooters are using red dots
but at the beginner level it can slow
you down because what you want to do is
you want to get it perfectly centered
and like you just said you stop moving
well your iron sights are moving too you
just can't see them so we'll do another
tip so when you're loading a magazine in
a pistol I recommend always grabbing it
like this and the reason for that is
that if I don't know any number of
scenarios that you're not in a typical
stance like I am right now you're on the
ground whatever somebody just knocked
you over if you have uh your finger like
this
you have kinesthetic awareness we all do
so you can you don't have to look at it
per se okay and it's just there we all
know where this is
right I'm not saying you can't look at
your gun that's that's another argument
on the internet but just just if you're
just trying to learn I would learn it
this way okay just because it's simpler
right so yeah you could always just do
that yeah all right he makes it look so
easy over the top
Red Dot away yeah I know that's the
thing the Red Dot changes everything it
does for me a little bit it's not going
to I know that's a problem
foreign
mess it up
it was like a pigeon that flew in front
of Randy Johnson
[Music]
almost all right here we go
you're out of rounds here we go see I
didn't even realize that because I was
looking at the dots as much as I love to
give Gerald cuff that's not bad no it's
very good
so this is actually a gift uh from
Walter Walter Patriots
uh that's a I guess a semi-custom the
way they do this um very happy you were
talking about how and if this is kind of
a specialty firearm but it does shoot
really nicely it does and what there's a
couple reasons for that number one it
has a match trigger which helps
additionally it's just heavy so it's an
all steel frame the gun's about I think
this one's like 43 ounces versus that
PDP just like 25 ounces so yeah it's a
significant difference additionally it
has match sites on it which are just
more precise than other ones and the
grip texture is also a little bit
tackier
the Magwell will also help you keep a
good grip on it as well I'll take a few
shots and then we'll uh obviously have
Gerald do it and you can blow us away
I do that right yeah all right we are
live uh let's go with the uh
generic and offensive swimsuit there's
no reason I don't know why we have
swimsuit on the Target no one so thumb
yep and what I would do is see I can get
my finger right there I would can't your
hand a little bit there you go man would
you have more purchase on it okay comes
up a little bit there you go all right
swimsuit well it's not really the same
as a Target but no it's not
oh
okay it's hard there's so many colors on
it I don't know we'll find out
we have no idea
yeah you know what here maybe I'll shoot
the Bud Light over here I think we can
probably see that more clearly by the
way do not we did not purchase any Bud
Light that's right it was donated from a
sales rep who couldn't move any more
product that's right yeah shockingly yes
[Music]
thank you
I don't really know what I'm aiming for
I'm kind of aiming for the bottom of the
view the center yeah Center top of the G
all right am I okay yeah you came up
Geralds do we want to use this one yeah
that'd be great let Gerald give it a
whirl okay so still finger off the
trigger okay and see if you can feel
that difference in the real place that
you're gonna feel the difference on this
is on follow-up shots yeah so the next
shot correct how fast your sights will
be on target okay so if you want to pick
the speed up once you get a hang of it
do that and you'll see the difference
okay
[Music]
thank you
try to speed up
feel the difference yeah definitely that
wasn't bad at all like it was much
easier to come right back to it yeah so
you said it was much faster and so
that's what you're talking about the
speed that I can get to the next round
absolutely okay hold on for context drop
that magazine Gerald
I got a fresh one let's let the uh so
there's a defensive rounds it doesn't
matter we'll do an episode on that by
the way defensive rounds hollow points
it's not it doesn't explode uh inside
you like people have put it in they are
better for uh defensive uses uh but uh
that one is just it's okay we can use
those let's watch Mr gear do it like a
pro
[Music]
thank you
I like it but yeah it's a it's a sweet
shooter I aspire to be that someday and
now people can see why I shot with a
technique that I was teased for years
but we can explain why with a revolver
okay this is loaded now everything that
you just taught correct but of course I
would lose my thumb potentially with a
revolver because you see this cylinder
Gap if your thumb is over there there's
gas that escapes and so uh the way
people shot for a long time and now they
people say tea and saucer or tea cup tea
cup okay so this is how I shot
everything because I learned how to
shoot on revolvers first
um I'm gonna use a single act because
double action I'll probably won't be
very good but
um
and that single action where you would
the hammer like you would see in
the films but you'd most likely use a
double action which is where you would
pull this
all the way through you know the range
of the trigger
[Music]
there's no real way to make sure I mean
you open it up so make sure people know
it's not uh live but hey you know what
that's not
that's not bad for a three-inch barrel
revolver I mean it's
different than others well yeah I would
assume there's an up Tuck
yeah some revolvers are will rotate
different ways Smith and Wesson
revolvers all rotate like this the
cylinder so if you're trying to line up
which one you're going to shoot that's
how you do it
[Music]
so what I mean by that is the not shot
round is right here so as the as I
pulled the trigger it will rotate into
this chamber
and we're out basically getting rid of
uh the ammo is pretty simple on most
revolvers it has this Rod right here you
just push down on it the gravity do the
work yeah and then if you're in a live
Shooting scenario right you reload it
like this
[Music]
and you kiss your ass goodbye or you
just use it as a hammer yes exactly it
is great for pistol whipping and for
killing people in Italian restaurants
which we would we don't advise no no it
does happen yeah it happens we don't but
we're not supporters of it no we don't
Advocate but it does happen
okay end of day everyone's least
favorite part Gerald's never done this
I've never done this at all cleaning
your firearm now to be clear there are a
million different ways to do it yep if
you have a very high uh level like
competition guns you're going to treat
it differently most people at home want
to know okay how do I clean my firearm
after using it to make sure that I can
keep it battle ready as it were and
there's a pretty simple way to do that
agreed okay um yeah so if you have a
semi-automatic
um obviously every gun's going to
disassemble a little bit differently on
these we've already verified that we are
clear which is important always verify
you're clear before you do this so we're
going to let our slide go home uh point
in a safe Direction pull the trigger
pull back slightly in these two tabs
pull down slide will come right off this
is the basic components that you're
going to assemble your gun to obviously
the gun can be disassembled much more
than this but for average maintenance
you do not need to do any more than that
these are what they would call CLP so
you have some that are cleaning like
more so solvents and then some that are
very specific lubricants which we'll
probably use more with the rifles
that'll be another installment with
these basic hand guns uh you were sent
up CLP for most people works fine which
that stands for what uh well depending
on the brand it's either cleaning
cleaner lubricant protectant or cleaner
lubricant and preservative depending on
the brand and it does all three yeah and
then this is an old school one that they
created I don't know how much of the
folklore is true Germany they wanted
something that they could use it would
be fine for All Metals Woods as well as
leather holsters so I've used this
specifically for revolvers because they
often sit like in a leather holster and
it's very friendly to what is called
ballastal people will argue about it
it's worked pretty well for revolvers
generally speaking if you don't know
what Lube you're looking at would I
recommend for a cleaner lubricant is
something that's petroleum-based there
are
vegetable based cleaner lubricants I
don't recommend them but if you're vegan
oh I mean if you want to eat it sure
um but I don't think petroleum I don't
think they have a problem with it oh
it's because of fossils maybe or
something without your eye protection I
like the looks like the glasses these
days so what I personally do typically
is I'll start out with a barrel and run
either a patch or this in this case a
bore snake through it you're going to
start with the heavy end here that's
weighted for a reason
to go through and you don't put the CLP
in first it depends if I was using a
patch I would yes okay
um with a boar snake I generally don't
you absolutely can that's a valid way to
do it and what you want to look for when
you're looking through to see how clean
your gun is is look through the rifling
and you want to be able to see the
rifling without a bunch of crap in it so
before you start cleaning it just look
and you'll see there are things in there
you want to get those things out well
how's mine doing since I've never
cleaned it it's doing all right but
there are things in there and we want to
get those out good and the guy who
doesn't change the oil in his car and
just crosses his fingers right and so
it's late to work all the time and also
on semi-automatics you want to make sure
that your feed ramp this area right here
which is where the bullet hits and then
goes up and in is clean because that is
key to reliability so additionally uh
basically all of the metal parts
that are wear Parts we're gonna hit with
some CLP
um I personally like to take a brush and
brush it around make that CLP work
because what the CLP is doing is
actually constantly breaking down the
carbon that's in there so so even if you
don't get all of it out of there when we
clean it up here in a second it's still
going to continue to break down that
carbon it's also going to help with
lubrication so CLP is just your friend
yeah and what I've always done that's
worked pretty well for me is I'll do
exactly what you're doing grab that
basically a nylon toothbrush right
anything they have they have a firearm
brushes but some of us now it's not
going to scratch it'll be pretty safe
correct then I'll wipe it down with a
t-shirt some kind of cotton cloth to get
rid of the excess that's where I was
going to go next yep and then Spritz it
one last time and make sure there's no
excess and usually only takes me about
five minutes we just did something right
there I wanted to point out so we we
hold the this so where did you spray in
here because as somebody who's a newbie
I'd just be like spraying all over the
price and you didn't do that no so what
you want to think about is where your
contact points are so on a semi-auto
generally speaking they're going to be
right here right here right here and
right here okay and then additionally in
your trigger component area here what
you don't want to do
the thing that will get you in trouble
is if you start fishing around in there
and digging around in there okay uh
there's very small Springs in there you
don't want to do that basically just get
everything that you can see uh that is
there yeah see okay um clean that up
anything beyond that is armor level
maintenance so this is you've brushed it
and so so then you'd wipe off the excess
with a t-shirt yep
no not fooling around in there okay fool
around with that too much you'll go
blind okay pistols have a breech face
which basically what that means is it's
right here where the actual bullet sits
when it's being fired and so you want to
make sure you clean under there as well
um specifically on our extractor which
is this piece right here which is what
actually pulls the rim of the case out
and you want to make sure that's clean
so it can get a good purchase on the
actual rim of the case okay so you can
see this is still that's oil with a lot
of you know it would have been deposits
carbon deposits or if people you know
some of the what I do black powder okay
it could be black fine all right
Minerals Copper all that with your black
powder semi-automatic yes exactly
so yeah uh wipe all that out here's what
I'll do and then
what then you can correct me where I'm
wrong what I would typically do after
I'm using CLP is do it's tough sometimes
with an aerosol kind of just yep a light
that's a little too much obviously get
rid of the excess and what you want to
see uh probably you want to lubricate is
all the wear points so like we just
talked about the touch points up front
touch points on the rear where that
slide is actually riding on those rails
um and then as you shoot your gun you'll
see where but I'm not sure if the
cameras can pick it up out here in the
brakes on but you can already see some
wear there on the barrel so wherever the
wear is that's where you just want to
put a little bit of oil a little bit of
oil right there
starts blowing right in Gerald's face
right it's okay it tastes tastes pretty
good now with a revolver same kind of
thing uh because a lot of Steel where
you can see with revolvers right this is
where you'll often get remember we
talked about that yeah that cylinder Gap
that's where a lot of that gas escapes
so that'll get uh dirty with something
like ballast all because it's actually
pretty friendly to metal and wood what I
do and you can tell me if it's right or
wrong again I've had five different
people push me five different ways I
know that it's wrong I soak it yep I'm
good with that and I'll do it and each
of the cylinders kind of soak it
sometimes I'll soak the whole thing if
there's a lot of
and with a revolver one thing that kind
of sucks
it's not the easiest thing to do is you
have to run this bore snake through each
one through each cylinder just throw it
in like a bucket of that stuff you
actually probably do it really yeah oh
well hey they have those just throw it
in shake it around a little bit pull it
out you know so they actually it
vibrates by itself
so it's a real thing for the lazy you'll
see this here what we'll do is I'm
showing you but there'll be a time lapse
it still wouldn't take you more than
about eight minutes right to run this a
couple times through each cylinder once
the soak is done that's where you take
the you take the brush to it it loosens
everything brush it up wipe it down with
a T-shirt and then once you close it up
again spray it with something like a
bell sole it's actually a really nice
preservative wood yeah and just wipe off
the excess the microfiber cloth is
really more so sometimes people make
this mistake you don't really want to
use this for actually cleaning the gun
from the oil use it kind of at the end
to finish it right if you're looking at
really excess and have something nice
and shiny like that's kind of a piece of
jewelry something that that's you know
in my opinion piece of jewelry yeah the
Wall Street BK is is beautiful like keep
that one and keep that showroom ready
but
we literally just cleaned that in real
time this would be done you know another
minute or two another couple of minutes
and you're good to go hopefully this
helped you guys thank you again to
Walther for uh providing somebody's go
check out Mr guns in here he does if you
want to dive in deeper you know you can
go as as deep and as intricate as you
want this is again designed for people
who are afraid of firearms hopefully you
know basic safety how to shoot how to
maintain your firearm how to make a
choice some other videos come in rifles
uh and common myths and we get to shoot
the jail which is fine
uh hog hogs in Texas you couldn't afford
Hogs well okay
Ted Nugent had a hey I had a conflicting
schedule got it
and our thanks to the folks at the tdsa
range in Ferris Texas it was hot but it
was wonderful if you like this video
click like consider subscribing or
comment below and of course consider
tuning in to the live show Monday
through Friday 10 a.m Eastern right here
on this channel